[Music]
[Applause]
so i assume it was more or less correct
so i will carry on with my duolingo
lessons
and
by the way duolingo is a terrible and
great platform at the same time it's
very easy to use but the lessons that
you get there
well when i was trying to learn spanish
from it i got phrases like
tu
which translates to your father is an
elegant person because this is basically
what you need when you go to a stranger
on the street and you start the
conversation with it to padre
so yeah remember if there is one thing
that i want you to remember from my talk
that would be it
all right enough of this banter at least
for now my name is rafael and i work as
a senior software engineer at hudger
where we create tools that can help you
better understand your user's behavior
and gather feedback from them
among many things that i enjoy in the
product engineering i especially like
data and playing with online experiments
and this is what i'm going to talk about
in this session
to exp to explain the concept of online
experiments
i will dig into history
so let's move back to the 18th century
when the first a b test kind of was run
sailing exploded at the time it was the
literally the golden age of it
but sailors had to face many challenges
and scurvy was one of them
the concept of vitamins was unknown back
then
and this curvy was leading disease and
the cause of deaths of of thousands of
men
around 1750 james lint a surgeon sailing
with the royal navy was trying to figure
out how to help his comrades suffering
from scurvy
so he ran an experiment he treated his
fellow com his fellow sailors with
different types of acid-like additions
he had a hypothesis that they could
purify their bodies from scurvy the
surgeon divided the sick men into six
groups
the first group received seawater
the second one
cider the third one citruses
the fourth one a paste made out of
garlic and mustard so very creative
the next one barely water whatever that
is and the last one
cellpharic acid solution
so of course the group that received
oranges and lemons got better after a
few days
it seemed to be a huge success
the
surgeon proved that citruses could be an
effective cure to a disease that was
causing
was a cause of death of hundreds of
thousands of men over the years
all of that in a kind of clinical trial
or if you prefer an ib test
but then unfortunately he made a mistake
so the surgeon started saving
serving as semi-boiled concentrated
juice as we know today the process of
boiling destroys vitamin c
so the juice had a very little or no
effect at all
but lynn didn't retest his findings
in another trial so the cure wasn't
known promoted or adopted for thousands
of years
apart from this being a cool story
to tell at about vacuum party there are
two larynx from it
the first one is to
not trust your gut feelings
and retest your changes
and always base your beliefs on the data
if it's available to you
and the second one
when life gives you lemons don't always
make lemonade out of it
i hope that was for a joke not for
drinking the water
all right what are the online
experiments that we know today
many of you work at companies where the
a b tests are run regularly perhaps
perhaps even even on a huge scale you
might even have the dedicated platforms
built in house for this particular
purpose
but even with that in place there is
plenty of room for making mistakes
and i will confess
i have made a bunch of them on the way
so their the learnings and results were
quite rough
so today i'd like to share with you a
bunch of things that i wish i knew
earlier or understood better
but first let's do an
alignment for those who might not be
familiar with the concept of a b testing
kit
model testing model a b testing means
having two versions of of application
shipped to your users at the same time
and checking which one is performing
better
so
let's say that we have our user base we
have changes that we want to validate
and test
one version of the app that doesn't
include the changes and the other one
that has these changes
and we assign our users to these
versions randomly and representatively
in a typical ib test we measure a
certain metric that we believe should be
influenced by our change
it could be for example an engagement
click-through rate or a completion rate
so we what we want to do is to have a
scientific level a scientific level of
certainty that our exchange has an
impact on the metric and check which of
the version is performing better
so then quoted peter drucker yesterday
you cannot improve on if you don't
measure
and we want to understand which one is
performing better just like james lee
james lynch did in his experiment
and by the way a betas
aren't meant only for purely business
stuff you can also prove that
accessibility changes and performance
changes also influence the business
metrics and if you can prove that you
can
get more allies if you want to convince
your stakeholders and this is at least
how it has worked for me
all right the other team of online
experiments is the canary releases that
i will be also mentioning during my talk
they also rely on presenting a different
version of the application to a
percentage of users
it could be either a complete version or
or a part of it that is hidden behind a
feature flag
usually it's done to test how users
users will react to your changes gather
feedback
test
infrastructure or simply there is the
chance of introducing major bugs through
everyone
to give you a better picture of what it
can look like this is how facebook has
been releasing the changers for years
so initially they do a release to
internal users
then this is the c1 level
and then to two percent of their user
base and then finally to everyone
so at any any point of this
gradual rollout it can be stopped if
anything is on fire
in some cases i will be mixing the term
of canada releases along with the ib
tests
under the single theorem of online
experiments
so you know these are well established
and unknown practices that contribute to
correct decision making
and reducing the risk
but yet some mistakes are easy to make
and even if you have great tools in your
hands
mainly because math isn't always easy
and there is plenty of situations like
situations that can surprise you
especially if you are if you are unaware
of what could go wrong
so i will ask you this question
how many of you can safely say that you
can truly understand the meaning of
following sentences
so these are example sentences that you
can find in tools that are supposed to
help you with running online experiments
and you know as we dive into this topic
we can literally crash into an iceberg
there is even more
more of terrence like this and yes we
have excellent tools to help us with
with such things but it's worth
understanding the foundations in order
to determine if we can trust those tools
and how how to use them properly
so to make it a little bit simpler i'll
use an example let's imagine that i have
a food truck with pizza
currently on average 10 percent of
people stopping by decide to buy my
pizza
but i have a very controversial idea
i have a hypothesis that adding
pineapple will attract more customers
so the get gut feeling tells me that
serving pizza with pineapple will
increase the percentage of buyers to 12
percent
so in my example
the version of normal pizza let's say
is the control version
and the pizza with pineapple is a
variant
so let's go through a few terms that are
going to be useful for us
the first first of all when we create an
experiment we have two types of
hypothesis and out of which only one can
be true
the first one is null hypothesis it
roughly states that there is no
difference between the variant and the
control version in terms of the metric
that we measure
so to make it a little bit simpler let's
use our pizza example
it roughly says that adding pineapple to
my pizza doesn't influence the number of
buyers or shortly speaking that might
change doesn't influence the metric
the second one is alternative
alternative one so it says that our
change has a direct impact on the metric
that we measure in my pizza example that
would be adding pineapple to my pizza
has impact on the number of buyers
or shortly speaking the change does
influence the metric and pineapple is a
perfect pizza topping and that's proved
by numbers
so what are the errors that we can make
in accepting a wrong hypothesis there
are types the first one
is that the type 1 error it means that
we are accepted accepting the
alternative hypothesis when the null
hypothesis is correct and the type to
error is the opposite when we accept the
null hypothesis when the alternative
hypothesis is correct without digging
into too many details
those errors can happen on a higher
chance when we jump to conclusions too
early by not running our tests long
enough
and when we have float data and more on
it in a moment
last but not least we also have two more
important parameters that define our
tests quality
the first one is the confidence
you can think of confidence as of
confidence that if my variant wins it it
would be also true for the entire
population so let's get back to our
example
if my test shows that adding pineapple
works it's also true it's the chance
that we it will be true for the everyone
stopping by
we can also define it as the chance that
type 1 error won't happen and we rough
we usually define it to around 95
percent
the last one so bear with me please uh
is the statistical power it roughly says
that when i detect my change has no
impact on the number of buyers it would
be also true for the entire population
so in my example if my test shows that
adding pineapple doesn't matter it's the
chance that will be true for everyone
stopping by
and it's also defined as a chance that
type 2 error won't happen usually set to
around 80 percent
all right i know it could have been a
lot especially in the morning on the
second day of the conference and
especially with such controversial topic
as pineapple and pizzas
so i hope i haven't offended one anyone
by the way i asked organizers to have
this kind of experiment during the lunch
but they didn't agree so they are taking
much better care of you than i would so
i think that's worth clapping
[Applause]
by the way the pineapple on pizza is
just for pure purely scientifical
reasons you know
all right we know the basics so what
what are the common pitfalls that people
face in online experiments
let's look at it chronologically
assuming we have a hypothesis and
metrics defined we must determine the
sample size so
it will be the number of users that will
be assigned to both the control and the
variant variation of our experiment
it's important for us to acquire
meaningful results and this is exactly
why we need that
we don't want to accept a false
hypothesis because of not running the
test long enough
so we cannot just start our test without
defining how many users are needed for
the test instead we need to calculate
this all the sample size up front
and you will find many calculators on
the internet for that purpose but they
will differ
some of them will
let you define more parameters upfront
for example the test quality parameters
parameters that i mentioned before
if you are looking for a decent
calculator there is a linked one
slides are going to be linked on twitter
and i confess my first experiments were
a complete disaster
they didn't include this
step and well this was one of their
problems
and yeah
when i was just starting with
experiments i simply started them around
the calculations on the way whether i
had a winner
and well this is where we get to another
problem which is the picking problem
as we run a b tests we often want to
check the results
we have fancy dashboards in our in our
tools
so we might often see that our
metrics are showing a difference between
the versions of our ib tests
so we open an online calculator enter
our data and well we learned there is a
winner
but this is one of the worst things that
we can do
so let's get back to my pizza example
imagine that out of first 10 people
stopping by
five decided to buy my pizza
so does it mean that my variant is so
successful
or was i just lucky and i and i observe
an early extreme
so the very same thing could happen just
in another scale in our experiments and
from a statistical standpoint the chance
for it is huge
so we cannot end our tests too early
what we can do
so first of all we need to reach
required sample size at least in most of
the cases
this is why the first step the one that
i've mentioned before is important
secondly if you want to use our
real-time data
we can use sequential testing sequential
testing defines certain criteria under
which we can end our tests safely but
most of the time we will need to stick
to required sample size if you would
like to learn more on sequential testing
there is a fun there is a fantastic
article on this topic
last we can also trust engines that do
some kind of magic
that enhance uh traditional statistic
frequency statistics to shorten the
experiment duration for example vw
switched more to bayesian approach and i
will be talking about it in a moment
and there are two links to papers for
both optimize and vw which are the
leading platforms for
for a b testing
all right
let's play a game let's guesstimate
so
for my pizza example
what do you think
what would the required number of people
for my pizza example for both the
control and and the variant versions or
so a sum of of people
so just to remind the current percentage
of buyers is 10 percent the expected
percentage of virus would be increasing
to 12 percent with my changes and the
quality of this is defined as 95 percent
for confidence and 80 percent for power
to make it a little bit simpler there
are four possible answers to this
question
so
who thinks it's a please raise your hand
who thinks it's b
and c
and d
so
i think a was the least popular and then
d
and the d is the correct answer
so this is just to give you a picture of
how many users we need for in our
experiments in order to acquire
meaningful results
and this is where we get to another
problem i know a lot of problems
insufficient traffic
so one of the most common problems in
online experiments is having
insufficient data to conduct our tests
quickly
and time is of the essence
first of all dragging experiments in
time means that we are risking being
influenced by other other factors
secondly our industry is highly
competitive so we need to simply move
fast and run tests quickly
so how can we make them shorter
with having the knowledge of of the
issues that i've mentioned before
well in traditional frequent statistics
we can simply go for lower confidence
and power and accept more risk
so depending on which on the type of
test we are running
if we are okay with accepting more risk
for the sake of shortening the duration
this is the simplest way to go
the second idea is to consider one-sided
tests one-sided tests are basically the
types of tests that give you an answer
whether it is there is a statistically
significant change only in one direction
of your or of your metric
so for example if we were on test and we
are willing to accept the variant only
if it wins that would be a way to go
also last but not least we can
experiment with biasing approach
the bayesian approach roughly gives and
gives us an answer about the chance that
one variation outperforms the other
so to make it a little bit simpler let's
get back to my favorite example of pizza
pineapple
pizza with pineapple has 71 percent of
probability
for attracting more buyers than regular
pizza where the 71 percent is just
changing over the time as we run the
experiment and hopefully with the time
we get to a higher percentage
as we get more uh more more people
involved and more confidence
so
over the last oh this could be more
digestible information for people who
have no statistical background and also
just the fact that we get this
information updated with every piece of
data flowing in might be more practical
for us
but well there are some problems with it
we've seen an increasing adoption of
this approach
for example by vwo the engine that i've
mentioned before
but there are some
errors to that are still present in this
uh in this approach so
yes there are some parts of this model
that are hidden
and if are willing to
give it a try please to dig a little bit
further before you jump on the native
so my recommendation if this is an
option try to combine both by asian and
frequentist approaches and make
decisions being aware of issues of both
so i've mentioned that we shouldn't end
our tests too early at least most of the
time
but what if something is off we need to
learn why
so in most of the cases we won't learn
about the y from the numbers that we
measure and i'm not simon sinek so i'm
not going to tell you start with why but
understanding what's going on in your
product is crucial to running successful
tests and there's this is where
additional tools might come might come
handy
so first of all
error login and technical metrics could
give us hints that something is wrong
with our test setup or simply the
variant
and last but not least we can also use
behavioral
analytics and watch session recordings
heat maps ask
questions in surveys to users
about their experience so
one of the examples that i like getting
back to is the rollout of the 3d secure
in the platform that i was working on a
while ago
so
basically for those who are unfamiliar
with the concept of 3d secure it
requires you to authorize your payment
with additional text
code from a text message message for
example
so we expect that this kind of change
would influence the metrics but we
wanted to understand it better
initially we have observed a drastic
drop but because of
having the
setup of analytics we
seen that
the metric were dropping though that
raised some additional questions so we
watched a lot of recordings to
understand the behavior and in the end
we fixed those issues in those issues we
started the experiment and the drop at
the end wasn't that significant
so i mentioned that we've modified
variance
what should what should we do in that in
such case
well any change
in variance means that we are
influencing the distribution of the
metric so we cannot
continue experiment despite making any
modifications
from the point when we make
modifications it's basically another
experiment so we cannot just glue
together two pieces of data at least not
easily that rely on different variables
therefore whenever you modify variance
remember to restart the test and try to
have as stable surroundings as possible
there are two
issues that i wanted to mention more so
interference we might forget that our
customers can be connected across the
versions of the app that we ship
these connections can lead to unexpected
results one of the great great examples
of that situation was described by
linkedin they were basically
experimenting with notifications
a
control group was the the group that
wasn't receiving the additional
notification the variant had some
additional notifications so what they
observed was that not only those who
received those certifications were
showing an increasing engagement but
also those who were contacted afterwards
but they by that group only those who
were
only though also those who were included
in the control group
so we had blurred data and this change
affected not only uh not only the
variant but also the control group
so there were there was no clear way how
to run the calculations in order to
determine if we had a winner or how it
impacted the midi metrics so to solve
this issue they created clusters of
users based on their networks
and it was allowing them to isolate
users between the versions of the
applications
so remember whenever you have a risk of
interference so the connection between
the variant and control version which
could lead to a float data
try to isolate them to avoid the network
networking effect
and the last one sample reaction
mismatch
sometimes you might observe that your
samples differ from what you had
expected so
let's say that i wanted to split my
traffic 50 to 50 percent but the
observed speed at the end of the
experiment is 46 percent to 54 percent
should i worry about this fact well the
answer is yes
ignoring it could be ignoring also the
fact or the hint of issues with our
experiment with the setup of it or of or
gathering the data
so we need to calculate whether this
difference is statistically significant
significant and surprised we have the
calculators for it
so
um yes whenever you see that
kind of a difference it's also important
to run these calculations and perhaps if
this is a problem
fix the issue and restart the experiment
all right enough of these issues
and the last topic that i wanted to talk
about in this session is the privacy and
ethics of online experiments
and it's perhaps the most important one
in my session
so a b test can be treated as a way of
manipulation or at least manipulating
the content
i will refer to an example from a couple
of years ago where a famous social
network experimented with their feed
so in that
in that experiment
they were showing either more positive
or negative posts to users
and it turned out that this kind of
change also influences their mood
the difference wasn't that high but
still noticeable
so let's just think about it
experimenting with mood
in the world where depression statistics
are
skyrocketing this is a huge risk
over the years we had also other
scandals with other companies for
example playing with a false perception
of safety
we are as engineers responsible for what
we do at our work
and we are not tools without free will
but yet we are a privileged group of
people who most likely understand these
topics much better than most of the
society
so the least we could do is to question
and carry about what types of
experiments we make
keep making people aware and fight for
the transparency
one way to tackle this issue could be to
create legislations that move that
enforcement transparency and would make
you require a constant from users if you
wanted to include them in experiment and
yes i know this could be very
controversial and you might be skeptical
about legislations
because we could end up with yet another
popover to go through
or an extra line in a cookie banner but
there are types of legislations that at
least partially do they work one of that
example one a good example of it could
be accessibility loss
according to companies specializing in
accessibility this is by far the primary
reason why companies have started caring
about this topic
there is a project in the usa night
in the early stages that is called the
digital act
which stands for deceptive experiences
to online users reduction
the tltr part of of the particular to
experiments is including a user
in experiment would require their
consent
so to sum it up running experiments in a
reality where we have
revenue driven world will always be the
case and we need we need to stand mild
full of these issues
there is a bunch of links that i wanted
to share with you uh especially the
first one which contains validated ideas
for experiments that are much more depth
than just switch over cta color
and
this is where i wanted to wish you many
successful and ethical experiments
created in a transparent way
just like adriana mentioned yesterday
remember that it's not boss or company
that's on the other hand on the on the
other side but real human beings
thank you that's all from me
[Applause]
you